[Music]
nothing beats a good old of a powered
main character troupe in anime there's a
certain enjoyment we all draw from
watching someone be overpowered that no
one else can touch
it's a fantasy inside a fantasy that we
all love to watch and thankfully the
anime genre keeps producing amazing
shows with overpowered emcees here's
some of my favorites
starting off the list at number 10 its
Tanya from the saga of Tanya the evil
imagine not believing in God and in this
case a God who decides to give you one
last chance to become a devout believer
and turn yourself to faith by
reincarnating you as Tanya Vonda Girish
off a super powerful magical girl in the
middle of an alternate universe in
Germany during World War one the saying
is God works in mysterious ways
but this is more like God works in
batshit crazy ways Thank You God though
for giving this psychopath superhuman
physical and magical ability such as
flight energy manipulation and beam
emissions and if that's not overpowered
enough Tanya also possesses masterful
marksmanship explosion manipulation
making bullets explode with the power of
a nuke telekinesis and just in case
self-destruction
I wonder if Jesus had all of these
powers too he was just too much of a
nice guy to use them
at number nine its Tatsuya Shiba from
the irregular at magic high school
Tatsuya is the epitome of an overpowered
main character he's like one of those
perfect main characters who can do no
wrong he's incredibly intelligent and
part of the most elite military units he
can read the activation sequence of a
magic spell and recreate its raw code in
reverse order to cancel the spell they
call his abilities miracles and there's
good reason for that because of Tatsuya
is genius he can make backups of himself
in his mind whenever his body's in
critical condition he just thinks a
certain thought and his physical body is
restored to the state it was during the
backup even when Tatsuya is on the verge
of death he can instantly restore
himself to a save point in the past
moving on to number eight we have Shiki
from the garden of sinners Shiki is from
a family of demon hunters children born
into the Ryoka family are generally
raised with a male and female
personality
Nishiki has incredible endurance agility
and strength she is capable of
dispatching a horde of undead or even
spirit light beings especially when in
possession of a katana however what
sensor above and beyond most if not
every single being in her universe is
her mystic eyes of death perception an
ability that allows the user to perceive
the death of something living or
nonliving in the form of lines and dots
on the target when cut or stabbed it
causes the object to be sliced and
killed with ease or in the case of the
dots arrays of being or objects entire
existence completely
[Music]
at number seven it smelly odors from the
seven deadly sins
many odors is the former captain of not
just one but two of the most powerful
groups in the world his skill in battle
is legendary and his inherent power is
full counter this allows him to reflect
attacks aimed at him back at the enemy
but would double the power so the
stronger his opponent the stronger the
full counter is Plus like all members of
the demon clan he's also capable of
manifesting the power of Darkness to
morph into various shapes for a variety
of purposes such as forming wings to fly
reattaching limbs and enhancing both his
physical and magical abilities next on
the list is any Isshiki at number 6 the
main character in yashiki Ichiro has a
family that hates him his only friend is
his dog Hanako but worry not by being in
the right place at the right time
he's struck by a mysterious explosion
and gets an upgrade to his old sick body
with an advanced mechanical body so the
sad old man is now suddenly an amazing
robot with all kinds of overpowered
abilities his 58 year old brains
replaced with a supercomputer that has
the capability to use built-in programs
which thankfully didn't go to a 9 year
old because all they do is play
fortnight on him his shell is pretty
much indestructible and maybe it could
be damaged by another robot but
thankfully there aren't any other evil
robots out there and just to name a few
more powers enhanced senses robotic
senses telekinesis healing properties
full techno Kinesis technological
adaptability arm cannon multi target
laser self-destruction and most
importantly the ability to shoot out of
his finger while saying for buck buck
buck
and number five we have mob from mob
cycle 100 siggy Okayama is just a kid
trying to live a normal life you know
maybe find a cute girl for himself play
some sports have some friends but sadly
for him he's socially awkward and also
probably the most powerful espera in the
world the abilities he suppressed since
childhood are multiple and overpowered
the name of the show is a looming threat
of what will happen if he ever goes 100%
he doesn't have full control of his
power and as more emotional distress
hits him the more of his power leaks out
where 100% of it would put entire cities
in danger even a low percentage of his
power is pretty much unstoppable by
anyone some of his abilities include
telekinesis astral projection energy
transfer and most useful in Espoo fights
the ability to drain other Esper psychic
energy
[Music]
at number four it's God or sensei from
assassination classroom everyone has
that one weird teacher in school but at
least yours isn't a humanoid octopus
whose color change is based on their
mood that can move faster than a jet
airplane and that plans to destroy the
earth in one year after effectively
taking over the world he decides to
become a junior high school teacher and
his students just love him calling him
korosensei which is a combination of the
words unkillable and teacher and oh boy
have they tried to kill him every day
they execute multiple assassination
attempts on their teacher in order to
save the world and gain 10 billion yen
from the government might I add chorus
sensei has so many abilities that makes
the kids jobs much harder including
antimatter physiology camouflage
absolute defense and energy laser
shading skin like a snake skin that's
indestructible and others can wear as an
Armour regeneration superhuman speed and
way too many more next on the list at
number three it's Momonga from overlord
as the only player character in the
world full of NPCs he's the most
powerful being in a Drasil thanks to his
own devotion to the game but also his
guild mates he's a powerful magician /
necromancer and has all of the powerful
items of NPCs his guild has collected at
his disposal he has 718 spells that he's
memorized some of which are damaging
spells and necromancy spells that allow
him to conjure powerful and dead beings
the list of his abilities is too large
to fit in any video under 2 hours long
[Music]
number two it's a local art from Helsing
ultimate Alucard works for the Helsing
organization and their main purpose is
to fight vampires and other supernatural
forces in fact he's probably the most
powerful vampire out there
he seems to be pretty much invincible he
fights like a masochist to entertain
himself he toys with his enemies first
giving them a chance to carve him up and
only then fighting back the damage he
takes regenerates quite quickly he also
manages to find joy in the little things
such as killing his enemies killing his
enemies and another hobby that includes
killing his enemies killing is pretty
much his favorite thing in the world and
that's why it's good for him to have so
many abilities such as regeneration the
ability to manipulate blood soul
absorption vampiric speed and many more
he's basically like the Swiss Army knife
of abilities if the Swiss Army knife was
actually used just for killing for being
to exist in one punch man he's a main
character that's so overpowered that he
suffers from an existential crisis as
he's now too powerful to gain any thrill
from fighting form a hero for fun turned
pro he's a bald ordinary looking man
that's often underestimated by his
enemies only for them to get one punch
Kayode he's quite the mellow person but
his strength attracts the company of
many other powerful characters both
friends and foes the origin of saitama's
powers are according to him wait for it
a year and a half of doing a hundred
push-ups sit-ups squats and running 10
kilometers daily for Americans out there
that's like 6.2 miles not the most
impressive backstory but nevertheless a
very fun
I hope you loved this video as much as I
loved making it because some of these
shows are my favorite shows thank you
for the love and support you're giving
me on these videos the transition to
this type of content was kind of scary
for me but the response has been
positive and that just makes me try that
much harder so thank you I've also
created a patreon account too so please
check that out if you have the time it
would be great for you to do that as
well don't forget to leave a like if you
enjoyed this video subscribe if you want
to see more anime related content and
leave a comment of what top-10 you would
like to see me do next I'll see you next
time on Binney tube
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]